says we're going live says we're going
okay all right and we are live what's
going on everyone hello and welcome to
the round table with the stream team and
we are talking this is where we end up
talking to a lot of amazing content
creators and I know I'm jaded was the
bosses supposed to be here today but he
unfortunately had a personal thing that
came up so he wasn't able to make it but
I ended up calling my good friend
knowledge here he is a twitch streamer
and he does I met him through a fellow
streamer and we actually became really
good friends and I figured who else to
pick to be one of our first guests here
but my buddy knowledge expect a lot of a
lot of crazy conversations I'm hoping so
true and probably some nice cool
refreshing beverages so so I would like
to welcome knowledge today to the
roundtable how are you how are you doing
well first officer thank you for having
me here
wipes ecstatic for this opportunity and
all of you out there thank you for
enjoying this moment now for the rest of
the show I will tell you this I am
unfiltered that is your first warning
you know oh boy this is gonna be a fun
evening
so Vagabond oh how you doing man how you
doing Eric good evening to you so uh so
why don't you go ahead and tell us how
did you end up wanting to become a
content creator why did you end up
starting to stream why did you end up
starting to you know get into this type
of world into this internet world if you
will that's a good question like
seriously like at the other day I kind
of look back at it like what was I
thinking why would you do this to
yourself wait I mean like the pressure
that the the South like doubt the the
drama that surrounds you playing when
individuals had Mane that cook like all
of that stuff like what was I thinking
like I said back
holy cow like mommy I mean the main
thing that started me with this it was a
dare I had a major dare with a root yeah
man like with a really good friend of
mine and I was just like all right all
right you Darrin my dumb self to show up
on camera with my ugliness and explain
the people how I feel about gaming at
the time when I'm gaming I don't know if
I can multitask that well but if you
let's go
so like I started to do the whole like
streaming thing did it um with Halo 5
when it launched I did it on an Xbox and
I had a laptop and the laptop was what I
used to like pretty much to stream the
gameplay well the video footage of me
and then like you stream lamps and I
learn stream labs and I went from that
to like alright let's see how far we can
take this and then I started to find out
about OBS and I started to create you
know very slow notifications and I was
like I like the aspect of just playing
with the streaming stuff didn't I do
actually and then um
yeah man it kind of grew into this whole
like I dare you to do it for like a year
and I was like sure why not
it just rolled into a type of just I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this every day it was
like a random hodgepodge of light I
think my friends will support me they
may not and if they don't and I guess
they're not friends but the point became
after a while it was just like I kind of
like I like the unfiltered nature that I
am and when I'm on camera it's even more
unfiltered to the point where is like if
I'm going to talk to you this is how I
feel yeah right whether you can see me
or not this is how I feel and it it
became a release really um like nowadays
you got a lot of this mental thing where
like people were just like you know what
you know gaming is an addiction and you
have a problem because you gain and
that's a thing that one of my co-workers
is acts
they told me that I have an addiction
I'm like no I would rather be added into
gaming to something like drugs or
alcohol or something like well I was
gonna say something else and I don't
remember but yeah like cigarettes like
things like that yeah those things will
kill you
video games what they end up doing from
what do they end up doing for you what
do you what how did you end up not too
doctor change the conversation we can go
why are you good man we can go back to
a-put
oh look because you're saying that like
that person told you it was an addiction
like what what did you know this is
after like 67 years being in a
friendship with this person but whatever
the point is you know it is one plus it
was a side combo that they had with
somebody else and they told me like oh
listen it is and I'm like okay but I
mean to go back to you a question like
the main thing was it's not an addiction
because it became a source of therapy
yeah for a while it was like no one was
in my channel like I'm not a big
streamer I'm not you know 15k 20k 200k
I'm like 400 500 actually I don't even
remember what my stats are but it's like
I got a couple of subscribers here I got
a couple of subscribers there and I was
like I'm in the middle of transitioning
after that whole year thing and it was
okay at the time and I transitioned I
sold my house and moved in with a friend
of mine and next thing you know me and
him were like let's stream together and
that is what changed my life
straining with my friend became my focus
so then my channel was like knowledge
and friends and then it became my
buddies focus and he realized he could
grow from it and he was getting therapy
as well like yeah you won't admit it cuz
he's he's a colorful E word in
individual side side note everyone I
said to knowledge was like a balance I
would love for you to be on this show
but I need to do
because he just goes crazy but I
appreciate you trying
I've been around though I've been around
sorry it's it's one of those things
where it's like god help me but it's
just like me and him realized that the
therapy between like telling people how
we feel about something and how we are
interacting with the world around this
Wow penguin thank you for the follow in
the world around us is what made us
realize that gaming was necessarily an
addiction it was a realization that
gaming is what helped our minds release
ourselves from the BS that surrounded
out the reality of the world that we
lived in so like everybody has this
politics that they live on right about
their world their perception and this is
this is how I explain to a lot of people
is like your perception is your
perception but is not the reality in
which you live like the the creator of
God help me god help me Cohen Rick and
Morty the Creator Rick and Morty said at
first to this this this individual who
tweeted him on Twitter and explained to
them that you know I know you're feeling
depression I know you're feeling the
suicidal nature and like you feel like
this all of this stuff is bent up inside
you but that's your perception of the
world around you it is not the reality
in which you live so understand that
your perception can always be changed
and that changes would helped you grow
as a person and as you grow as a person
you will come into your own and when you
come into your own your reality will
literally flourish into the positivity
in which you present to it and he might
explain a lot about it and that I don't
even like Rick and Morty I'm not going
to lie I don't like
either so don't worry about it so please
could tell you but the Creator will
forever get my support for what he did
in a social media standpoint to explain
to someone that their situation not
necessarily was their own but something
that others were living at the same time
and that that was key to something that
I realized what streaming and it was
like you know this happened like two or
three years ago and I've been streaming
for like two and a half years and it's
like wow this man really got deep with
it and it explains everything
and you kind of realize when you're
streaming that you're not really
streaming for yourself right right it's
tough definitely it's feel like it's
never for you exactly you're streaming
for the people that watch you because
they are entertained by you thanks pingu
for the bits and you start to realize
the release from streaming is almost
equated to walking out in public subway
eat fresh um so basically you in sorry
um you start to realize in yourself that
the individuals that are watching you
are not entertained by anything but you
being you and once you've realized that
you kind of realize that your own
personality is acceptable yeah you know
what I mean like no matter how goofy
awkward you know innuendo ish you may be
like whatever is wrong with you mentally
is obsolete right it's a matter of I'm
entertaining the people because they
like me do you feel like you have to go
almost into a twitch persona or do you
feel like you can just go on and be
yourself because there are many people
that go on to twitch and into into mixer
into other streaming platforms or even
onto youtubes itself in YouTube's who
says that YouTube it's a good point and
and they end up not really
they had to have to have their own
persona to be known it's almost like
some of the comedian's they aren't the
way that they are perceived for instance
everybody knows like Bob Saget
he is like a dirty mouth comedian but he
was the father of full house who was
like the most clean-cut individual ever
it's like you know like he had that
persona of being that clean-cut
individual and then when people saw him
and stand up they're like holy mackerel
what's going on exactly yes so okay so
feed into that right that is their
perception of something that to them was
real written and the thing is your
perception of what someone is being
based upon an action that they're being
paid for and this is the equivalent into
it like this is it
that was perfect this is the equipment
at which an action and in persona that
they're being paid for in twitch may not
necessarily be who they are and you
think back and you've realized something
that I don't think a lot of people take
into account when they look at twitch
streamers and actors and whatever is
that they're actually people yeah that's
like we have you I've never been to a
twitchcon have you ever been to twitch
gone mm-hmm I've not been to Trish got
either but I've heard people that say
that they go there and it's like it's
like these twitch streamers and these
other mixer streamers are like
celebrities to them and I will say it
first that when I was at PAX East with
the guys I was walking through the area
and I saw Dino - and he is someone that
I was watching forever and he is very
noticeable he's got this awesome like
beard mustache and I ran wrong so Amy
and I read I read okay so we ran right
up to I like ran right up to him and I
was like hey what's going on how you
doing you know you know you're also yeah
and it was one of those things I was
just I I couldn't not say hello to him
and it was and then after the fact that
real I was like holy mackerel I geeked
out on them
and yeah you did and after the fact I
messaged them on Twitter and I was like
dude I'm like I said hello to you we
spoke for 20 minutes I never even got a
picture I was like I wish I had
something to remember that I'm like so
the next year we were to pax east I'm
like we're definitely getting together
but I fully understand you know what I
tell you I'm sorry to interrupt I just
you and this is something I think
everybody needs to take away from any of
the stuff that we're doing as as people
and when you're when you meet someone
and this and this is like celebrities I
and i'ma say this because I've done this
this is how stupid and like unfiltered I
am you ask them a question that's [ __ ]
I mean mmm that's obvious like you ask
them a question that's obvious
do not ask them a question that they
have to sit back and think about do that
later pick s em an obvious question
here's an example
are you a person and what if they don't
laugh they're staying in their persona
yeah you see what I'm saying like think
about this everybody if you if you're
watching this and you're taking note
realize something about celebrities and
this is how you do it you ask them
something that's obvious and if you get
a trumped-up answer you get a response
as out of the norm they're still in
character and let it happen but nine
times out of ten I'm gonna tell you this
is what I did I walked up to bro man at
Guardian Con 2017 and I said you know
what I want to kiss your bald head I was
like I'm sweating right now okay I don't
care what he's like not today
that's when I realized this was a real
human being and I took a photo with him
we laughed about some stuff and not some
I was like you know what I'm not gonna
take all your time because that line in
front of him
behind me is the reason I can't sit here
and have a beer with you right now he's
like what would you find me later on
let's have a beer
like cool right I didn't find a later
one but in the process of me taking a
photo with him she snaps is right behind
me making the funniest face I've ever
seen and got the most viral hits I've
ever had on Twitter 5,000 people saw
that that's that's crazy it is like I'm
nobody but I cause this this random
moment just being myself with this
supposed celebrity that people can't
talk to right and I did the same thing
this year I was like dude I know you're
exhausted take your time take a breather
whatever he had been doing interviews
and let's stand all day and it's like I
was like you know what you want me to go
get you something cuz like you look like
you're thirsty but like you know I must
send you some nudes thirsty but you
thirsty yeah and you know me and him
have this weird little repartee and
anytime I say something in this chat he
acknowledges that from time to time and
I'm not saying he knows me he doesn't
know me he really doesn't but he knows
the name he understands that I came at
him with the realest conversation that
he has ever had
amongst the random ass people that be
like mmm that's the random people that
end up acknowledging him as a celebrity
that's like how can you beat that
I would never go to a cell I'm just
saying I get starry-eyed like everybody
else
you know I geek out but I'm never gonna
go up to a celebrity and ask them some
question that they somewhat ruse
question like so when you became truly
truly known what was the key pivotal
moment I'm like you know a hey do your
pits think you need me to pick check you
real quick s the dumbest thing cuz
that's the breaking of the ice bread it
makes you a real person it makes them
understand that you you are you're there
you're in you're in the moment you're in
the moment exactly so so that brings me
to a question so what when you're at
Guardian con like you you went you hung
out with a whole bunch of different
people and so when you were down there
what was your favorite part
what was your favorite part of Guardian
con you know this is gonna sound really
really cheesy and it's gonna be really
boring but I enjoyed the 24/7 gaming
that was so dope cuz I remember seeing
bunch of stuff saying oh man I can't
wait I'm streaming I'm playing and
you're playing like I remember seeing
dauntless I I'm not gonna lie
there is a lot that you can get from
those cons right and then like you know
people tell you like oh I got a chance
to play this for the first time I can
care yeah what I wanted to do was walk
over to captain ash bacon and just be
like you know that stream deck I got you
how's it working out because it was like
it was one of those things was like you
you're never the person that they
remember but you will always be the
person that made you remember do that
that's how they know you you are well
that's the thing like what I meant when
I mad a now and he was probably the
first person I met outside of the whole
streaming universe when on that con and
I I made a connection with him that now
every single time I go into his channel
he's like hey what's up he's even been
on ILP on Islands podcast how hung out
like I was with those guys and you know
it's it's pretty it's pretty fantastic
to have that relationship with those
people that because you never really
expect to do that
right right what what are the cons are
you planning on going to you plan on
going to any of them next year or what's
up that um the reality of my situation
like anyone elses is that money is a
thing is a problem like 90 no problems
and all of them are money right yeah so
one minute is me
maybe working exactly so like the
reality is like right now like every day
I uh I stay home I try to work out you
know to keep my mind busy which doesn't
work all the time I'm not gonna lie I'm
lazy everyone is like we're all gamers
for the laziest people who come across
and like finding motivation is really
difficult like this BeerBelly
right here ain't going nowhere son so
when it comes down to it you gotta be
able to look at what you really are you
know what I mean and like realize like
the income level I have is not
equivalent to a streamer that's making
six figures the income I have is not
equivalent to someone who has a good job
with insurance and benefits whatever I
have I need to take this money and go
one two three you know anything like run
this is what I need to do this is what I
have to do and this is what I got right
how does all three of those get me to
where I need to be hmm and that's what I
do I literally said it'd be like alright
it's gonna cost me two grand to go to
gcx next year I may change the name and
I'm not happy about the name change I'm
not gonna lie
I don't like generic names for a con
because that means you're about to sell
your con to the highest bidder I don't
want to mess with you if you're doing it
but at the same time I know the people
involved and I'm expecting big things
from them period yeah if they're Gwen
generic there's a reason they trying to
overcast packs twitchcon whatever
they're trying to over here talk about
what was formerly destined to come
correct destiny Khan Gardi and Khan now
gcx whatever you want to call it you
know when when Danno when Jana was on
the stream he he's actually on the panel
for gcx and he actually told us the
reason why they changed it was because
they wanted to pull in more people they
wanted to bring in more people to to to
destiny well former Destiny's count to
gcx because they wanted to have more
developers they want to have more
collaborations because it's just like
Coachella you're not gonna see different
musicians intermingle it you really have
to listen content right though I don't
know what
Fashion Show of America music I was
gonna say um oh my god
Jingle Ball Gino Jingle Ball now those
collaborations between different
developers that want to have them
collaborating between different types of
of people even in streamers cuz that's
the only way the concert creators are
gonna get better and they're gonna
produce better content is what the
intermingling and that's why they're
doing that's why gcx is doing and so
that's that's me that's my little
defense towards it but that's that's you
know okay let me okay let me learn
something today
knowledge is a jack-of-all-trades
connoisseur of none so here's how this
works
I have hosted events of 5,000 people
people don't even know this I've done
things that people don't even understand
can be fathomed in their lives since
I've been in high school of helped
coordinate events over a hundred and
fifty thousand people I have also been a
part of things that you know football
events and things of that nature I've
done bars I've been a bartender I've
worked in an airport I've done a lot of
things and people were just like you
don't know what you're talking about
not be sitting like let me just put my
chair have you flipped your chair I was
just gonna start I would just like check
please specifically do what I wanted to
when I wanted to smell that's what the
dxracer behind me there it is so I mean
the thing is it's like there's there
four major aspects of a venue that not
I'm sorry an event when he clarified
because you know people kind of take
venue to a whole nother stratosphere but
there's like four aspects that you worry
about one location two timing three the
capacity that's that's a key aspect
there and then four is marketing look at
who they're marketing to right right gcx
is marketing to gamers how many other
events are marketing the gamers okay
done yeah you can go from Dragon Con
you're no momoka you name it every gamer
type is being advertising so your
marketing is kind of limited because
you're not gonna get like the random
slow B's that don't do nothing in their
lives and be like oh instead of going to
the beach today I'm gonna go to Dragon
Con and they're like no no no these
normies don't know nothing about this
stuff so your market is kind of slim now
you get into the aspect of capacity what
can you hold you look at what GC did and
at that resort mm-hmm we blew him out
the water last year well that's the
thing um look Hawk Neto he he's been
going every year since since it started
and he was there when it was like
literally like in a bar right and he
said that like it was crazy to see how
many people were were in there and they
started end up getting larger and larger
capacities and he said that this resort
was amazing he says it was it was like
perfect for for what it was that's what
you mean you look at the income that
these people have versus the money
they're putting out yes they've created
a separate nonprofit organization yes a
nonprofit organization must be plus and
negative at the same time so where is
your revenue coming from think about
this ladies and gentlemen revenue is a
major factor of a lot of these things
and when you're looking at the marketing
budget the capacity the venue the
location that you're you yes
you're kind of set on a particular thing
and
people get pissed off because they can't
get in or the time that it takes to get
in becomes a detriment to their fun
you're screwed so how do you get
yourself around that screw
it's that screwed mentality not just a
bigger place not just bigger marketing
but someone else has to manage and
maintain so watch what happens I'm not
this is not a matter of I don't like or
I don't respect this is not this is
literally logistics you got one you add
two you got three this is literally it
and when you look at what's happening to
gcx the next option that they have
because goth Umbro men have said it
King Magic has said it they sell out
events and venues like it's nothing
mm-hmm yes they can make money but if
you create a separate organization
you're no longer worried about making
money it is about the event so what is
the next best step for an event that was
just held at a resort that not only sold
out but had lines waiting and people
coming in every minute of every hour of
every day
yeah gotta go bigger mm-hmm well yeah
we'll eventually go bigger um I wouldn't
I would expect them to not but I
wouldn't I would expect not expect them
to
I would I would expect them to go bigger
for venue over time definitely I can I
would see that so what what would you
say is your favorite game that you are
streaming right now do you are we really
asking this question yes I am right now
Bordelaise because you are a lover of
the looter shooter genre Oh see you ask
the hard question right there
see that's see cuz I know I know how I
met you we both met yeah yeah in our
Boyd NT stream yeah
- which is another looter shooter we've
done that we've done anthem together mmm
we have I can't believe me to death
listen I will say this right now anthem
was not a bad game they shot themselves
in the foot you can't tell me they
didn't shoot themselves in the foot
you're not wrong so don't tell me it's
not it's a good game but you can't take
an expectation and expect your
publishers to meet that that's the okay
we will sit there rant about that all
night but I know I know your you love
those looter shooters but like I've seen
you play other types of games that is
correct
so so what would you tell what would you
say I can't even say I'm a variety you
know what I'm gonna call myself I'm a
Trier
I will try any game that looks I'm not
kidding okay listen I'm from the
cartridge generation and I'm calling I'm
coining this right now ladies and
gentlemen if you are of the cartridge
generation you understand the level of
expectation and demand it's two
different things
am I wrong right right right is a good
idea right gansan was a good idea where
the lands 1 & 2 was fun right right but
let's be real the cartridge generation
you had trial and error and you allowed
a lot more in the car contra everybody
knows the code right you have am I wrong
you have to do in our game exactly the
code so let's be real that was a bug
that was accepted by the cartridge
generation now a bug in the game today
ie and I'm gonna pull out examples boy
here we go
anthem alright anthem you could use a
level 1 assault rifle and anthem and
still do this more or to say
name in jazz a legendary alright let's
go into borderlands borderlands right
now you got local sakes you don't messed
up rim me you've got local saves you
done messed up Oh over watch you don't
made a new character that's capable of
not just healing but doing more damage
than anyone else
alright let's go even further let's go
look destiny let's let's go so they're
just just a forewarn you know everyone
here are huge destiny fans love it too
this is how I know life just a little
disclaimer let's be for real destiny -
you can literally between season to
season hold on to a that crosses over
into a whole new aspect of the game and
level you up and someone thinks it's
cheating and exploiting and whatever but
it's a part of the game it's a mechanic
and every raid runner for world first is
using it right now and has always used
it so at what point are you gonna just
accept this as part of the game oh when
are you gonna realize your high horse is
not necessarily a horse but a small
chair that has been propped up by as
much of your BS as possible except this
stuff and move on people oh Jesus
alright and anyway on that on that note
you you were saying earlier when you you
were pretty much almost like a bet to
start streaming yeah you read you said
you started streaming with what Jim halo
5 halo 5
console or PC so when you did you end up
using an external to stream oh you're
going on the hardware alright
let's go inside did you end up using the
hardware though you know what um people
don't really know about NBI inside of
like OBS but it's been there since the
beginning since 1999 um but OBS has been
using MDI for a long time that's what I
use I didn't even know I was using so
NDI uses a software based streaming tech
to basically mimic the idea of a capture
card you utilize the HDMI source in
order to stream it to the software and
the software then pushes it out to the
Internet eat I eat via your streaming
key like platforms like twitch and mixer
and stuff like that but NDI is probably
the most well known way to stream
console that people don't even realize
even exists in the first place and it's
sad it's you know what networking based
transmission of gaming is really sad
like you would assume like we've gone
past dala right mm-hmm
we're not I mean we've gone past the
human eyes perception of the refresh
rate beyond 60 Hertz you know what I
mean like we're we're in the realm of
like let me get 4k at 444 hurts okay
like we're in a whole nother realm now
of what we demand and it's not even what
we consume it's the demand let's be real
everyone supply and demand
if you supplied the bare minimum that is
no longer the minimum for 20 years ago
that becomes the demand like that's
literally how this works
every year we there's a new level of the
demand that these manufacturers of
software have to meet let them have time
to develop this stuff stop putting your
money into BS that it will never work
just give us some time if the masses
want to sit here and pay for pie max at
4k that's not really 4k it's upscale let
them pay
cuz when the 8k comes out and is
actually a Kay and you're sitting there
like
he saved up you're good to go wait I
mean it like use the tech that's there
yeah if you can't afford the stuff don't
knock somebody else that's using it mag
well is the best streaming like hardware
that's out there mag wells over 4 to
$1000 to get the best resolution needed
to stream you not wait let's be real
America is a great country in the term
of the word America but it is not the
best country in the terms of the world
of countries okay so hey when they make
one prime axes being made by China
except that it's being made by China
don't sit back and be like ah it's China
oh my oh my god oh we're gonna put a
tariff on them because it's chai get out
here they made it they did it better
there's no patent over there who cares
let them make it better because if they
make it better we can do it better it
was it made another question for you
would you would you recommend streaming
to someone like if someone who loves
playing video games is though is there a
certain criteria you'd want them to
stream with what was that no just do it
yeah just you don't know who you are
and what people want until you do it
right so don't get here when offer
perceptions right so that's because a
lot of a lot of because I've been to a
lot of different panels and stuff and a
lot of those streamers will end up
telling people if you want to stream you
can but you're probably not going to and
so that's something that I I'm very
against like I told me when I'm honest
with them and I tell them it's very hard
- yeah it is very hard to get into the
industry and
the what makes what makes like me want
to say hey you should you should stream
you you're gonna be good
it's not a third streamer and not if
they're a good gamer right if they're a
good networker to communicate to people
Judy how do you feel do you agree
disagree with what are your thoughts by
the way is that a panda to your left
oh it is PO I love I'm sorry I get
easily distracted by pretty things
continue that's fine I rock Voldemort I
don't care what people say Baltimore may
look like a turtle but Voldemort was the
realest wizard and Harry Potter he never
went to that BS that Grindelwald
is doing right now and okay anyway okay
laters you started this you started this
hey it's not it's not my fault Neville
Longbottom is the real hero of Harry
Potter continue you're not wrong oh you
know like okay here let's be okay I mean
let me refocus there's one thing that I
want to tell everyone if this never gets
out yes whatever it goes on the internet
I'm like multiple different platforms so
it is giving out is watched that's
that's on them I've never said something
as real as what a mother say right now
in the context of streaming if beauty is
in the eye of the beholder
then fear is a detracting from success
did you just make that up earlier is up
from some stuff from some that's
literally made up right now okay okay
beauty may be in the eye of the beholder
but fear will always be the detriment of
success so take that as an understanding
that if you fear what is beautiful they
you'll never succeed that's literally it
I don't look beautiful I am NOT
beautiful bro mans not beautiful Goff is
not beautiful in the context of what
society has deemed as beautiful it is
not they are not beautiful they're not
big tittied as females they're not big
dick whoa okay I'm sorry
to you pull the deck okay all right here
we go I'm Marie I'm a rephrase that for
all generations rephrase that I love to
cook sorry about that
cut that out that's fine beauty is not
an eye of the beholder in the context of
streaming because the reality is the the
streaming world in which we live in is
not noted by whether or not you're a
female or male its are you entertaining
that is the most true concept and that's
the most subjective concept the society
could ever make for us Kevin Hart is
listed as one of the most successful
comedians of all time in this current
moment but if you go ten years back Dave
Chappelle beetle you go 20 years back
Richard Pryor beetle you go more years
back than that there's there's a ton of
folks the point is the moment that you
have chosen to live your life is the
opportunity in which life has given you
that's that's a that's a knowledge quote
right there you are not you are not
perfect I am not perfect but you do what
you have to do to show your purpose and
people will be attracted to that hmm
I will give you I'll give you a great
clue and this is this is gonna go to one
of the people that's reveal my channel
and stuff like that or whatever if
they're still here there was an
individual they saw my channel and came
in via another networking source and I
will not say networking is not the
reason for the success I'm just gonna
say it's part of it
but they come into my channel they
subscribed they didn't know what they
were getting themselves into they're not
of age but they came into my channel
right they saw my channel they saw I was
hilarious they saw it was funny they
communicated with me they became a part
of my community and in less than a month
I happen to just give them a gift for
their birthday no calls no need to ask
in response nothing and me said that I
have to it was just you know what you'll
be the nice guy do it it's me this is
what I do
right I just just saying that is a part
of what I'm saying is the aspect of what
makes you who you are and B you don't
stop being you because someone else said
something yeah you are the reason for
your success and no one else is the
catalyst you are the catalyst that made
someone else watch you so if you want a
string do it mm-hmm period what's going
on Lord Cognito how you doing buddy busy
at work thank you for stopping in my
friend yeah he is the leader he's the
leader he is the head Horseman if you oh
there you go so what what game would you
say was your biggest draw for people to
view you to watch you so okay let me let
me do this first a lot of people play
towards the game mm-hmm I gained because
I play that's that's the truth I game
because I play yeah that's it
that's it for me I don't care I don't
care that this game is coming out dead
by daylight is what everybody told me
you don't understand how many streamers
told me and this is another thing when
you're networking don't be afraid to
network with people bigger than you I'm
smaller than you because
networking in general is what it means
it's networking it doesn't care if
you're higher lower equal to you network
yeah don't get that twist in that aside
that's a that's another thing a lot of
people like we were talking about
earlier a lot of people assume
networking means people who have made it
know you can learn something from
someone who is not made someone you know
has streamed and stop streaming asked
him why
that's networking yeah well there's
there's some times where you and me have
had long discussions Australian about a
lot of about a lot of people oh my god
can we stop talking about how big my
dick is come on man I told you I told
you this is going to be a trial and
error for me okay I told you watch it
okay watch the liquor let me try it out
a little bit but all right
sorry sorry I have the worst jokes in
history don't watch me so he does have
like I have to sit back like man it's
true but yes so there's been times I'm
saying before there's times that we've
spoken online about many different
topics and one of them is that same
thing it's that you know networking
doesn't matter if you're big small let
you know whoever you are sure wait what
matters is you know the person because
that one person you don't know if it's
gonna jump into you know like another
person or for instance this is no joke I
will I've already been spot talking to
him he will eventually be on the show
and I can't wait to get ahold of him his
name is uh respawn respawn TV preferred
yes okay so um I knew respawn when he
had three four or five people on his
channel
me his buddy blender but and my and my
friend the squall all of us were in his
channel when he was super small he can
blender but yeah
and we all we all were close we all
helped him and we all supported him and
everything and then he ended up growing
and growing and growing in to the point
where he finally got he finally got
partnered and you know he still is that
same person that we know from when he
was that small thing but he you don't
you never know who's gonna be now now I
have another person who I've been
talking to his name is Kiki baristas
awesome guy he is the best literally the
best and he's like the number one person
that my wife likes to watch stream and
like he he ended up like very small he
ended up blowing up and then never got
partnered and ended up having to move
and he ended up losing everything but he
like all of his followers and things
like that but we're still there to
support him cuz he's awesome he's a
great guy so wait wait what year was
this I need a sure this was last year
okay can I interrupt real quick and I'm
gonna say this real quick sorry even if
you're going through life mm-hmm you can
still one do reruns that's been as of
2017 and you can also do a lot of live
streaming that can be rebroadcast on
your stream that explains your situation
and I'm not doing this to dis no no no
no no it's you know knit like if I
donated more to streamers that I've
watched for longer periods of time than
I should I've donated more to them
because they told me their situation
Brent and I'm not saying you ask for
money I'm just saying it's a level of
communicate I think I think we should we
should clarify something real quick
networking is a matter of communication
if you want to succeed you communicate
to your network that's that's a clear de
notion of what's going on like what in
the network the main network is your
channel yes
friends or other channels just like TV
yes continue I'm sorry just wanted to
clarify just keep you can't sit yourself
in a silo and expect success you gotta
get out of the silent get out the hens
nests get out your nest you know and
feed the information to people so
they're aware of your situation because
if you don't tell the I don't your mom
died your dad died it's a sad thing but
the people who follow you follow you for
you mm-hmm
not because you're your persona like
Russ be real right now in the market
that we currently live ninja is the most
successful not because he's has a
persona but because he is who he is
hmm you're not following ninja because
he's mixer whatever you're following
ninja because his persona is literally
him yeah so communication did you I
don't know if you read this article or
not but Kotaku put out an article on
cocoa Nation yeah I don't know if you've
read it or not but no I haven't but
literally when he broke the the most
consecutive days of streaming I don't
remember the amount that he did I think
it was it was a crazy number and he
ended up saying that he ended up missing
a lot of things in his life because of
it and I asked myself I was like there's
never you know I couldn't no I couldn't
do that sometimes like I just want to
say taking a day spending the time with
the missus see you guys later
or if I'm streaming and my niece comes
over you know and she comes over and
she's like Uncle Pete what are you doing
and I'm like oh I'm just playing some
games of streaming while you want to see
and she's like okay and she'll sit on my
lap for a little bit and then I'll be
like hey guys I got to go by him because
I want to spend time with her like that
those are those things that I find most
important to me so that's why I like it
amazes me that people will stream every
day non-stop no problem for one of the
things in the article actually said he
said I streamed from my phone one day
from the floor of the
after him because I was so sick throwing
up it's like you why like I don't want
to see that like say hey I'm not feeling
well can't stream to the guys have a
good one you know but you know what you
know what he's over different okay okay
so let's be real there's different
generations right now inside of the
streaming space Amazon Microsoft who
else is streaming wait does mixer and
twitch other big - I know but there's
another smoke Instagram so because
you've got at YouTube and Facebook yes
thank you
they're all working with this concept
right now that's outdated from 10 years
ago
all right so technology moves every six
months this is a guarantee it's not
changing this is America yep hallelujah
but every six months tech changes them
in phone comes out with a better
resolution there's new video recording
tech that's now made public there's new
gaming technology being integrated into
games that we've never seen before
ie for example respawn utilize the ping
system that is now being requested in
every shooter game ever made yeah and
it's so big that fortnight was like bump
it we're gonna take two billion and make
it like let's be real the point is
you're asking for society to meet a need
no no don't think of it it's more of a
want mm-hmm okay you're asking a child
society to meet a want but you don't
need it and the reality is streamers are
the same way they're trying to meet a
want that generally generally a little
bit a little bit of generation
generationally yet area turn
generationally cannot meet up with the
once that society is asking for for
example a lot of people assume that when
a game comes out and this is the
assumption of society my
this is why every Kotaku article exists
in Forbes article exists society
believes that every new game comes out
reaches the current generation that is
at the time that the game releases and
anything that game does not meet up to
needs to be adjusted for the current
society that is using that game final
thank you for the host my dear you're
wonderful
the point is society is not predicated
upon the want of a generation it is
predicated upon the sustainable need of
that generation for tonight realized the
consumption need of their game every
genre every videogame ik every movie
every NEMA every dance they realized the
benefit of their game and they met the
societal consumption need but that was
not the games respected and expected
want no one wanted to John wick skin but
when they saw it they realize one thing
that nobody can take away from those
guys a fortnight their marketing and
their their inventing of their team is
top-notch
correct nobody can can take that away
from them you never know so because we
have gone on so many different rambles I
it's so true it's so true that um I got
a couple more questions so we're gonna
be running a little long right um let's
do so who are your favorite streamers
that you watch right now they you that
you would are like you know that you're
always in there like when they when you
see that they're live you go to see
I wouldn't use it as a monochrome like
uh that's not a monetary note of what I
consider popular but who do you say hey
I'm not saying who is popular
I'm not saying who is like the in the
know I'm talking about you like when I
when I log in and I'm like alright I
gonna watch twitch there are certain
people that I go is this person on this
is person one is this first month and I
go to their channels first so let me let
me let me take this one thing as a note
this individuals I respect this is the
this is the this is the monochrome of
how I denote what is valuable for my
viewing experience in my individual /
possibly generational gap because none
of you all may know I'm a 36 year old
man and in nine days nine days I'm
turning 37 you're an 82 baby oh man yeah
I I am also an 82 baby believe it or not
so I understand please continue
so when it comes down to it my watching
criteria is not dictated upon the trend
you know I mean like right now like
everybody's like okay a couple of weeks
ago it was Borderlands right everyone
was watching people with Borderlands I
didn't do that I went back to WoW cuz I
wanted to see their viewer rating so I
saw the Wow and I was like alright who's
in the top three lines because that's
the first thing you browse when you're
on your PC but on your phone that's like
the first of five like that's all you
see you know I mean so it's like you're
not scrolling that far no one's
scrolling through that thing no one
motion everyone knows me scrolling on
your phone
everybody knows yes but it's like let me
check yes I know right listen you've got
to learn some stuff today if y'all in my
channel right now that's the thing so
the point is you're watching something
that has to
be consumed for a reason and that's our
generation
we're not consuming media we are used to
watching ads that we hated everyone
hated that bounce bear no one liked the
bounce bear he interrupted our Sunday
morning cartoons you hear me I could not
duck the Rugrats because help me the
bounce bear can go screw himself up a
pole I don't care but it's a popular ad
that we all know and that's what I'm
saying it's like we recognize this we
recognize you know Rugrats we recognize
Doug's we reckon these are things that
we recognize so we watch the individuals
that recognize that in most cases yes
but as a streamer I stopped that I
stopped at about six months after being
on Twitch because my mind dictated
something other than what I wanted
versus what I needed I needed to
understand the market as a streamer you
need to understand your market if you're
not paying attention to the market and
what people like and what they're
talking about you're not understanding
why you're even on the stream in the
first place
are you there just because of you and
you want to do you then you do it you
know you you don't care right you know
what I mean but if you're trying to
build a brand you have context to do
what you need to do right and in most
cases I'll tell anyone if you're gonna
watch something watch it for a reason I
don't care if it's you know women who
are playing well with their chests out I
don't care
it doesn't matter watch it for a reason
I'm gonna watch it for a reason you know
what the reason is how many times people
post an asterisk of something that they
shouldn't be posting how many times does
it take people to recognize that this
person is not just streaming it for the
supposin indie window content right yes
I'm just reading but I'm watching it to
see how much this person knows about the
game they're playing and when they start
pulling out 10 20 years of content on
wow I'm sitting there like let me stop
yeah let me stop the video and listen to
the audio because right now there's a
it's relative because I'm a new player
yeah so that's that's how I dictate what
content I consume and and right now the
top streamers that I consume content on
is individuals that are relevant to the
games that I like to consume so because
I want them to tell me something new so
what you're telling me is like I'm sorry
the streamers you end up watching are
the ones that are playing the games
right now so right now for instance
you're playing Borderlands 3 I don't do
this often yes I am so what ends up
happening is you go to that Borderlands
3 channel the category scroll down and
then you'll just pick something out of
the first three or four rows and then
you'll watch whoever exactly right well
so oh at least four or five pages deep
because here's what here's what go on
you go under you go see I do something
very I do something very similar but
like I go underneath people that are
under correct yes 70 people yes look for
people that are under 70 and and then I
joined then I'll see what they're
playing and then I'll end up you know
going okay does it seem this person know
what they're doing or they're just here
for something and that's correct I when
the oh my god I'm blanking on the last
expansion for a final fantasy xiv came
out i ended up doing that and there was
a person a no brainer bringer yes thank
you thank you so when I went when I went
to that channel I went down a car I went
down a couple of pages and I saw this
one one woman who was streaming and I
was like there's no way this woman knows
what she's talking about I was like
there's no one else so I went into her
channel she was young I'm talking like
freshman college show oh no I was like I
was like does she know talking about and
she did and I was impressed so now she's
one of those people I go to to watch for
5014 stuff because I was very impressed
by her channel and that was because that
was the content that she was putting out
in attack one today
you know like people don't understand
like it's not an age thing that grabs
the attention of viewers what grabs the
attention of viewers is something that
gravitates towards what they enjoy you
know like people people discredit the
the title in a stream for too many
reasons like all I don't know what I'm
gonna use me but I'm gonna do this as
clickbait like or I'm doing this because
you know everyone else likes it I'm
playing this game today because it's fun
or new DLC content like titles speak
realms to the person who's streaming and
I don't think a lot I think a lot of
streamers need to pay attention to that
if you're gonna make a title that says
I'm playing with friends not you people
in Rando chat but friends yeah you know
what I mean like I'm playing what
viewers let's see who's playing with
viewers what viewers are you selecting
you know what I mean like pay attention
to that
you know I mean as a as a particular
consumer I'm looking for something that
works for me yeah if I'm planning to
play monster hunter world I need to find
somebody that's also playing monster
hunter world but I got every line the
whole game is its offense just
consistent with monster honor but no I
fully agree it's just it's consistently
changing and evolving mm-hmm so the
Holter but anyway um so yes so that's so
that's what you end up doing you end up
going yeah I'd take context do play
right oh right now I'm playing
Borderlands but I don't care about the
borderlands directory what I care about
is how well is the anthem doing compared
to remnant how well is remnant going to
you know I mean like these are the
things these are games I play if
dauntless going better then remnant then
I may think about playing dauntless
they cuz I got a lot of people that play
me play with me and dauntless because I
met 50 something 40 something whatever
rank and it means I'm capable of staying
alive while somebody else who just
started is not I'm gonna
i'ma carry this kid let's go yeah and
like I'm gonna talk crap about console
players because console players are
horrible in that game but that's the
context in which that game resides in
that I play and I pay attention but at
the same time is like I'm not expecting
everyone else to so when they're coming
on my channel for 5 seconds in dip out
I'm not stressing and that thing I think
the viewer account thing stresses a lot
of people out you know what I mean like
a lot of streamers are like oh I got 2
people today you know what two people
tells me someone's watching it doesn't
matter if it's 80 it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter at all let me have 0
people you know who I'm talking to
myself like this Bush is this Oh Bush
bush no no no Sam no Sam okay go
straight like I will say I won't talk
myself I don't care so when you when you
ended up starting streaming when you
ended up starting streaming how how was
your how was your family when you
started streaming or they think you were
crazy because you have a full-time job
and you just dream for funsies when you
get home correct
but made me start drinking you I have to
ask I had to ask one more hard question
before you before the fun question all
right so what's going on living so you
don't man
I told my father that I stream and he
worried about me I told my mother and
she doesn't care so first off in my
family my mom is like the dad you know
she don't care she wants me happy
yep and my dad he's
my son you know you can't you can't find
a wife playing video game you know he's
like he's like you need the know to
continue that's how everyone finds their
their mates but that's the thing is like
you know I told my dad I was like ever
since you know me so I I used to play
this game this game called ingress oh
it's an augmented reality game you walk
around points and stuff like that -
portals and things like that I was huge
to the point that I was featured on
there like episode there YouTube
episodes once a quarter
that's how huge Oh like I don't know if
you saw the episodes but my name was
even featured in a field report or this
guy showed up at an event in
Indianapolis talking to John Hanke like
he's best friends with you he's like
yeah yeah I am and as I always showed up
at the van and knowledge did this
acknowledge it this is where the name
kind of rim comes from like six years
ago I used to be a part of a biker gang
mmm that sounds bad a barter group
social group that sounds better
so I was a part of that and it's tough
half in and I had to leave from scratch
my nose enough but I had to leave um due
to I was too opinionated you can't tell
me to show you telling me did it sorry
it's crazy
I might have to lay I might have to lay
have you like asked me questions in my
own channel from now crazy
no but um the thing is like after the
biker gang the group um I had to like I
you know I not necessarily disappear
like that's not how it worked it was
just some stuff happened with me and the
president of the group that I was a part
of and I was vice president and I dipped
and after I dipped it became like what
am I gonna do and the name stuck the
main that stuck with me for the longest
time even before
like people were calling me knowledge
because like we're having right now
we're having conversations on stuff
that's deeper than how's your day well
how's your mom did you wash your bran
system really good did you expect it to
be this way
yeah I've always been expected to be
this way my entire life I've been called
either one of two things the mastermind
or the know-it-all
and then one person who's really close
to my family literally called me
scatterbrain because I don't know how to
maintain a conversation on a single
topic it's not possible for me I can
have 90 different conversations and
still remember all 90 conversations and
people will be like wait you remember
that only yeah that was kind of deep we
kind of went on a really interesting
tangent you don't remember us talking
about how the world is not necessarily
round but probably a spherical a piece
of who yes like most gamers have ADHD so
they can pull multiple conversations at
the same time and remember em all and
communicate perfectly well on it I'm
you're right you're right because this a
thing that that's one of the class
requirements of a streamer is to be
really multitasking honestly I can't
play a game and play it and then talk at
the same time I got a pause because like
I'm that not that multitasking but when
it comes to talking I'll talk to you
about nine hundred and fifty five
thousand things and stupid like so when
we were discussing how much I use the
profanity and my discussion but at the
same time we were discussing how
interesting the need is but like I
remember that whole thing six weeks from
now yeah I may not remember the exact
verbage but I remember the conversation
in context and start a whole nother
tangent in it's great I love it and yes
flannel you're absolutely right so when
it comes down to it it's like you know
you gain because you can write you know
you you play the games that you can play
because you can't play them but your
stream because you want to not because
someone told you to not because you need
because you want to and as a stream read
that weighs on you real heavy because
then you start to say well do I need to
stream today the reality is no no you
don't need to stream
every day and I tell people this a lot
and people think of me like oh you're a
contradiction to what every other
streamer has Holly Street no and back to
the carnage thing is like Co carnage
could have stopped
no one did no one has any disrespect for
this man to not view his channel two
weeks from the time that he needs to so
he can take a break and get himself
together no no no right which you want
to and because the medium has created a
platform that's capable on mobile or
portable or whatever you think you need
to you don't so so so what you're saying
is you had one parent that was
supportive and one that was not
supportive but did you know the tangents
done I finally got the answer out it
just took a roundabout waiting please
start doing podcast this is great no you
don't want this so I'm gonna ask you a
question all right
so I love to hear people's answers
because everyone has vastly different
answers for it and in one video game or
fantasy universe right what would it be
I'm talking like would you love to live
in Star Wars would you like to live in
the world Harry the wonderful world of
Harry Potter would you look to be in
destiny would you love to be in World of
Warcraft what would you wear would you
want to be a real Italy leaving us to
only gaming movies if you like hey I
want to be with like the Punisher like
in the Marvel DC Universe so I've
thought about this for a long time once
and there's an anime i watch called a
regular high square the rings
said once you thought about this warts
yeah I thought about it one time because
okay first off I'm a reality person
first answering the question reality
person and going back to what I was
saying before about the parent thing my
dad may think what he wants but his
perception is not my reality that we're
going back we're going back to the
beginning of this entire conversation
my mom's perception is not the reality
of Who I am
they made me but they are not me let's
get this straight so going back to what
we first stated your perception is not
necessarily the reality in which you
live your perception can be altered
change adjusted blah blah
the point is what I thought at the time
as how I needed to let's say if I wanted
to relive this life that I'm living it
is an anime that's called a regular high
school student and magic high it is
really great because the concept of it
is that magic becomes prevalent in
society after the year 2000 and be and
this is the turning point this anime is
at the turning point when magic becomes
the main force destructive in its
context but segregative also in its
context which was made it more real to
me because it took magic and put it in a
concept that was more realistic in the
society in which we currently live which
made it more approachable and acceptable
and consumable to me so when I watch it
and I always watch this anime and I'm
like you know what if magic actually
came into being this is exactly what it
would be your high school life will be
you determining what military force or
family you would be a part of that's you
know couldn't like using magicians for
military purposes and then if you were
happen to be this military force that
was so incomprehensibly
like genius then you would be the
incumbent up-and-coming force to control
all of what society could be because
that's what happened in America like
1776 you
no you had all these individuals take
that pilgrimage you come over here and
create a country you know what I mean
like Plymouth Rock baby like the point
is like we made a society a country
that's so well known is so powerful and
an eventually lost that power like
that's the the reciprocating historical
belief that's always saying history will
always repeat itself
and that concept being thrown out in a
magical context I would love that you
know please let me be reborn 5,000 years
from now I had I had written down that I
wanted to talk to you about anime but we
started talking about gaming there's so
much we never even got to it to get back
together and do this again soon so it's
up to the people the people wanted an
option so why don't you tell everybody
where they can find you the instagrams
the Twitter's Weber's if you uh if
anyone ever wants to find me they can
find me pretty much on Twitch Instagram
Facebook just search for K in 0 WL 3dg
that's my license plate for people so if
you're looking for somebody
yeah if you want to find me like it's
not hard it's really not I am the only
one without the e or the three at the
end there's nobody else it's not it's
not hard about yeah so fantastic it's
great so I'm just gonna do a couple
couple of quick shout outs old school
old school style he's he was one of our
you know round table mates who is unable
to make it today
he is under old school style on Twitter
l-boogie is elbow he OH - oh eight she
she once again she was out running
around she is on Twitter if you're
looking for her and MJ is a boss he is
on Twitter also as beta B ei TT y MJ if
you're looking for him and all of them
have all their information on where you
can find them all over on their pages
it's actually pretty much the pin for
everyone
so and I am peat also known as snow
though here and I am on everything as
snow though SN a l why do so if you're
looking for me
that is that I would like to thank
everybody for hanging out tonight
oh the chat is awesome I would love to
thank knowledge so much for coming
clutch he pretty much crushed it coming
in tonight because of the situations
that ended up happening so I do what I
do for my friends thank you very much
and we you are coming back and you are
going to definitely be we're gonna do an
anime one you're gonna get
I guess stuff to Todd I like shield hero
I have one those I've know nine shows
right now on rotation that I have to
watch every week on that is so crazy
it's so crazy season I'm going in every
season I go in so uh I just want to say
this show is going to be up on multiple
different platforms iTunes Spotify
Google Play all of those on Thursday
we're planning on doing that MJ's gonna
see if you can get that up there if not
I'll go do it myself
so if you want to check it out that's
fantastic if you are looking for to ask
questions to our streamers that we were
gonna be bringing onto the show by all
means email round table stream team at
gmail.com and our twitter is table
stream I know it's weird because of our
name but it's just too damn long and
Twitter doesn't like it so make sure you
do that and check us out so everybody
just remember keep dreaming big and keep
on gaming thank you have a fantastic
week everybody and we'll see you next
week bye everybody later